こんにちははじめ社長です相手口までちょっと時間がなくてつまんで撮ってるんです
けども私ここ今東京のお家でございますまあ押す事であのすばらく東京に言うんです
けどもあのう
pcr 検査ん
私が今頃のエイズにかかっているかどうかを加減する
県産 pcr 検査と高度で計算するのかないろいろの計さあを受ける機会があります
ので今回それを受けていきたいとおもいます
なんで受けるかと言いますとまぁとりあえず私こんな加減者の方と濃厚接触
タイミングがわからないんですけどそしてすぐしたと
怪我はその方が切腹期間だったかどうかやちょっとないのか不安になってきていてその
方が選曲時間だったかどうかとかその人の頃に完成するマネーなのかわかんない微妙な
ラインなんですよね保険者の方にも聞いてもなんか大丈夫と言われたもののやっぱり
さん投票に来るって事なんか人と関わる仕事をしに来てるんですよ共演
の方とか一緒にをソートする方の安心というか無方がかかってないですよっていう証明
心配されないようにするためにもあのもうちゃんと検査の強化だと思って受けに行き
ます
ちなみにここ最近肖像とが全くなく味覚も究極も問題なしでいつもなす倦怠感は常に
ありプレっぽい症状は出てないものの無償僧僧僧が出ない
方がいると言うのもこの度別のポイントらしいので本当にあの分かりませんされ
ちょっとしたら僕表せいかもしれないですね
陽性になったらこのあと結構することがバーって詰まってるんですけどもだ分全部
ストップになって
2時になると思います
そこがすごいちょっとイヤというかまぁ仕方ないんですよねもうアルコール消毒ては
めちゃくちゃして生活してきたものもかかってしまってたら仕方ないんで陽性だったら
仕方ないんですけども一緒にお仕事される方の安心してもらうためにもベアの今後の
仕事のためにも
古賀受けた方がいいのかなと思って受けてまいります昨日関東
巨乳ですけれどもこの戦火でも感染するかもしれないんで本当に読めないんですけども
全くどんな感じかわかんないんですけど
でも
はいお久しぶりでさせ3節はですというわけであれから2日が経ちました
抗体検査の結果をすぐ出たんですよその過去になっているかどうかわかる奴抗体検査の
結果から言いますと院生院生でした僕は過去に頃にかかってないという結果でしたパ
なら
わかんないですね検査はほぼ100%確実
にそうですとも言い切れるものでもないので検査結果的には陰性だったらであの過去に
僕はこの指にかかっていない抗体を持っていないという結果でございました
そして
pcr 検査でございます
なんかやっぱすぐに結果が出ないみたいなんで時間がたったんですけどもあのしっかり
と結果
いただいてきましたマジでまだ見ておりません子はいーで正直で少女とか全くないし
押す事で誰かと共演する時もそうされてきたぞと思っていたんで大丈夫だとは思うん
ですよそれではいえばなってれてなると怖いっすよね本当にめちゃくちゃパッと見よ
本当に
いきます
どれがどれかわかんないということで動かないというと一つ
やばいやばいやばいませ
あ
陰性だった
[音楽]
はあああああ
よかったマジでマジで良かったはいこちらです
新型コロナウィルス pcr 検査委員性診断書ちゃんと書いてある大丈夫で20 s
4型7月31日新型コロナウイルス pcr 検査陰性を確認臓器チェッカーネリー
pcr 検査ず大神我ところがいう数は陰性というのですと
いうことでございませんでしたーー
ます
[音楽]
よかったです皆キュッパが証明されましたんしてください
いいせいでございます
っていうことはこれからも高く気をつけなきゃいけないということなんですよ俺はこれ
からも気をつけないといけないしてこれ pcr 検査も確実なものではないんですよ
100%アナとは陰性でした
入れるものじゃないんですよあくまでそのかなりの確率では陰性だと思うんですけども
これで確定っていう言い方でもないんで今後もしちった的操作 distance 外出
する際に本当に細心の注意を払って
いきたいと思っておりますこれは抗体検査ですね抗体検査ウェッジを院生院生という
ことで全く全く買ってないんだ俺よく頑張ってる自粛本当にいなきゃマジで良かった
本当にも
子でよかったーーね
お仕事で東京を切ってるんですけどもぶっちゃけめちゃくちゃ怖かったんですよ
当て字日だって今302およびにとか完成してるわけでしょ
めっちゃ怖いじゃないですかエレベーターとか人と乗る時すら怖かった
息止めてましたのかなぜあの私の安全は各
今のところですけどされたんだ
よかったですということで検査なんですけどもなんかねこう体験者は普通に
c をめっちゃ抜かれましたこのでチーム越額でですぐ結果が出たんですけど bc
あるゲームは pc アルゲンさん夏場もめっちゃハゲって言って僕めちゃくちゃ言わ
れてるんで俺ってすぐ食べてそれで見られたらしいです何か
ネットで見るとね端に何かこう突っ込まれて寝息取られたり
いろんな方法があるっぽいんですけど僕もツバ裏れるあの pcr 検査ね
ジョジョ日本のいろんな恐れを切れるようになってきております静岡茶とねやっぱまだ
少ないね受け入れないですか何だろう銅鏡ができるとやっぱり徐々に女さんの受け入れ
場所が pc あるけど上で切って言うんで本当にあの僕はちょっと仕事上ですねその
仕事される方が心配されたり不安がらせることだけだけど
よかったねー
5を証明したいなと思って今回検査受けてきましたなんか受け入れることによってサー
モス陽性だった時にめっちゃ仕事に迷惑かかるしけどやっぱり狙っ計算で解くことは
大事かなと思います
東京の仕事以上今終わって静岡買えるんですけどもなんかこれでねだいぶないが快く
静岡にも帰れます東京行ったやつ帰ってくるってだけでも多分
地方
人達って怖いと思うねーまあそういう意味でもしっかり道路の検査していてよかったと
思いますあの学生の皆さんも8月で短くはあるんですけど夏休み入ると思うんですけど
も
あの本当に血を抜かずに位置を付けて下さい東京もね車から見てたけど結構マスクし
てる人とか多かったし多分あの感じだと一生増えますね外出るなって言ってる訳じゃ
ありません適切な距離
ジョッキー
新装される遺産ですいろいろなものを気を付ければ本当に日常生活完全にといけません
けども2にお仕事できたりね色んなことができていくと思うので大事な人の身を守る
ためにををも気をつけていきましょう
藤間強かって本当にもうも気をつけていますでは静岡に帰りますじゃあな
[音楽]
voodoo
あっちょ